my name's andrew evans and i was
infected through hemophilia treatment at
the age of five with hiv and hepatitis c
i developed full-blown aids at the age
of 16 and barely managed to survive to
the age of 20. andrew is one of an
estimated 4 000 victims who survived
what's been labeled the worst treatment
disaster in nhs history where patients
were infected with hiv and hepatitis c
through contaminated blood products it's
thought around 2400 people died many
suffered in silence because of public
attitudes to hiv the stigma was still so
strong against those people
frightened me to death
and so i kept everything completely
under wraps as far as that was concerned
i told nobody at school
um
i didn't tell even my best friends about
it
um until it became absolutely apparent
that there was
you know something going on that i was
ill and i couldn't hide it anymore
social care shall be the truth shall be
the truth after decades of campaigning
an inquiry was launched in 2018
former health secretaries and a prime
minister gave evidence no one accepting
blame or the argument for compensation
what had happened to them was
incredibly
bad luck
but campaigners say it was incompetence
reckless blood collecting methods in the
u.s and a lack of checks when imported
to the uk
the inquiries recommended compensation
and now the government has announced
each victim will get a hundred thousand
pounds obviously it's a very welcome sum
of money
if you split 100 000 pounds over 40
years of being infected it's two and a
half thousand pounds a year it will help
at the moment
for me personally to do
what i want to do most which is to
secure my family's future but i'm also
very aware of the people this doesn't
deal with at the moment
i'm lauren denise palmer and i
lost my both my parents
back when i was nine years old lauren
was orphaned by the scandal her father
was given infected blood and died of
aids in august 1993 he unknowingly
infected her mother who died in the same
month
while spouses of victims will get
compensation parents who lost children
or children who lost their parents won't
get paid
how can they have this differentiation
and this hierarchy between bereaved
families
i mean all their lives matter just as
much as the next person i haven't been
able to lead a normal life as such where
i've got the stability of having two
parents
for support and
to go through education and go to uni
uh
be able to stay at home long enough to
save to put a deposit on a on a home so
i haven't
haven't done any of that
this is a victory for people like andrew
but decades late and many like lauren
who've suffered are still waiting for
recognition jason farrell sky news